lance mccullers is going to be on the
bump for your houston astros on the
season he is two and one one out base
runner is dylan moore here is kyle lewis
there goes the runner the pitch is low
martine maldonado's throwing a good tag
by altuve for the out at second base
swing and a miss mccullers pumps his
right fist as he gets the strikeout of
kyle lewis gets the help from his
catcher maldonado justice sheffield in
his last outing last sunday six innings
a four hit scoreless ball seven k's no
walks here's correa the shortstop 3-2
high strike got him
well done by sheffield here's george
another two out rally here by the astros
on the ground right side base hit astros
take a one-nothing lead george springer
with rbi number 13 on the ear
abraham toro scores
puts a good
decent swing on it nothing too fancy
just taking advantage of open space two
out lightning
one nothing astros one out one on top of
the third odom looking for his first big
league base hit swinging it's a ground
ball it's fair inside the back at first
and there is the first career big league
base hit for joe odom it brings home
evan white who comes steaming around
third base claps his hand as he crosses
home
and joe odom has tied this game at one
in the third inning mariners have two on
got lewis
falling into shallow center field it
drops in front of springer for a base
hit odom is to third he's making the
turn and scores standing kyle lewis has
put the mariners in front two to one in
the top of the third right runner on
second base now for birthday boy here's
maldonado
and that's a liner in a shallow center
field that's got a chance to get down
and it does tucker around third he'll
score and we got ourselves a tie ball
game at minute made it's two apiece
maldonado two for two
astros and mariners knotted at two as we
start the fifth inning d gordon will
lead it off against lance mccullers jr
swinging a miss
odom an rbi single and a run score
get a miss got him on a curve ball tough
hitter here jp crawford's gonna be a
good one
swing and a miss lance strikes out this
side getting d gordon swinging joseph
odom swinging jp crawford swinging to
end the inning and lance is hoping for
some help from andre scrub to keep his
two inherited runners from scoring here
big 12 to six hooks and into right field
josh redick is there he does strand the
two runners for lance mccullar so five
and two-thirds of two-run baseball for
lance we're tied at two
astros and mariners locked up in a 2-2
game white on first base stolen base
earlier today he's got going again and
this time he is out at second base
maldonado guns down his second run of
the game
altuve with the tag on white for out
number two outside of the bottom of the
seventh mariners and the astros even at
two justice sheffield strong work today
it's dan altavilla who will work the
bottom of the seventh for the mariners
here is maldonado two for two today
good looking pitch
strikes out it froze maldonado he can't
believe it lead off man retired here at
springer tied at two
drag three called boys springer knew it
right away he nods his head frozen by a
slider at the knees back-to-back
punch-outs by altavilla instep's reddick
99-mile an hour heat shin high
and reddick takes a swing at it and
comes up empty daniel toville strikes
out the side in order
carlos looking for his first hit of this
series
that ball hit to right field hit pretty
well more back he's near the wall and he
puts it away carlos didn't miss it by
much but he's out number three we head
to the bottom half of the ninth inning
all tied at two the astros oh for their
last 13 against seattle pitching and
mariners will go back to their bullpen
for a new arm eric swanson so here's
kyle tucker
tucker sends one high and deep to right
field got a chance this ball is gone
walk it off kyle tucker
his first hit of the series and the
astros win this game three to two
on tucker's second home run of the year
made the adjustment got the head out and
now he gets to hang around with the boys
at a distance straw wears the ice bath
from julie gurio but a nice swing
to finish off a tough couple of games
and sweep the series for the houston
astros against the seattle mariners
kyle tucker connects with one out in the
bottom half of the ninth inning
got the head out on it
and jacked it
out of here to right field
astro's first walk-off of the season and
kyle tucker provides the big blast
and this is the social distancing
celebration afterwards